maintenant on pourrait inviter que une
personne à la maison à la fois
ce n'est un mystère pour personne la
pandémie due qu'aux vide a fortement
impacté nos vies la fête très
certainement un des aspects de notre
vécu qui a sur certains points étaient
complètement mis sous cloche dans les
moments les plus critiques de la crise à
première vue la fête n'apparaît pas
forcément comme essentielle et c'est
d'ailleurs selon ce prétexte que les
festivités quelles qu'elles soient ont
été sévèrement limitée par les mesures
sanitaires pourtant la fête est un
invariant de civilisation humaine tout
temps en tout lieu les hommes et les
femmes ont fait et font la fête
évidemment les festivités des sociétés
antiques sont bien différents dans leurs
formes des pratiques modernes cependant
si les significations et les fonctions
de la fête varie selon les espaces
géographiques et sociaux ainsi qu'au
travers des temps
la fête est une des actions qui comme la
musique ou le rire distingue l'espèce
humaine des autres espèces animales bref
la fête fait partie du logiciel une ce
que je viens de vous exposer est une
base solide pour la formulation d'une
problématique de recherche en effet la
fête peut apparaître comme une activité
incontournable dont l'humanité or cette
activité a été mis sous cloche depuis
l'apparition de ce coronavirus dès lors
on peut légitimement se poser la
question de recherche suivante comment
les individus se sont-ils accommodé de
la réduction des activités festives lors
de la crise sanitaire qui a débuté en
traditionnellement la paix est associée
au rythme des saisons ou aux différents
âges de la vie humaine la fête marque
ainsi un passage et atteste de la
transformation de la nature et des
individus souvent une idéologie
religieuse recouvrent ces changements
par exemple les fêtes traditionnelles
chrétiennes marque les équinoxes et les
solstices comme noël ou prennent en
compte les cycles lunaires comme les
fêtes de carnaval ou de pâques tandis
que les différentes fêtes et sacrement
individuel rythment la vie de chaque
individu on pense notamment aux baptêmes
communions aux mariages et aux
funérailles la fête devient sacré et
transcende le lien entre la nature
l'être humain et la société le moment
festif vécu dans les sociétés
traditionnelles et donc un moment
d'élévation spirituelle qui coupe le
quotidien l'enjeu est à la fois social
et culturel est donc très sérieux
dans la foulée de la révolution
industrielle la société adopte petit à
petit une idéologie matérialiste et
considèrent de moins en moins les fait
qu'elle soit religieuse ou païennes
comme essentielle la représentation de
la fête chez les élites devient négative
des philosophes comme you nous le
montrent est ce que les considère comme
contraire à la raison source de
gaspillage et constituant un obstacle au
progrès de l'humanité d'autres estiment
que les excès festifs sont contraires à
l'ordre moral ainsi au 19e siècle lors
de leurs homélies dominicale les curés
de campagne fustige les libations et à
la fin du 19e et au début du 20e siècle
ce sont les socialistes et les
communistes
[Musique]
qui trouve que la fête est contraire à
la prise de conscience politique et donc
à la cause révolutionnaire
à cela ajoutons le discours des
hygiénistes qui voit dans les dérives
festive des entorses aux bonnes
pratiques sanitaires c'était déjà le cas
passer de bonnes fêtes ça veut dire
passer les fêtes avec des gens qui sont
en bonne santé et donc la première chose
que l'on dit c'est que si vous êtes
malade et bien malheureusement vous ne
participez pas à la fête vous n'allez
pas potentiellement contaminé d'autres
personnes aient gâché la fête du groupe
en question bref la fête n'a plus la
cote du côté des intellectuels et
s'opposent à la bien pensante cette
condamnation de la fête a pour effet de
renforcer cette dimension transgressive
et excessive elle se transforme à
certains égards en un acte symbolique
d'opposition à l'ordre dominant de cette
histoire la fête a hérité d'une
ambivalence d'une part elle est
instrumentalisée par les autorités afin
de contenir le peuple mais elle reste
néanmoins porteuse d'une charge
subversive et de désordre salvateur dont
nous venons de parler à ce titre je
pense par exemple carnaval d'alost
flandre orientale reconnu pour ses
provocations à l'encontre de l'ordre
établi quel qu'il soit
la fête moderne se détournent
progressivement du modèle traditionnel
auquel certaines élites s'était opposé
durant l'industrialisation d'abord la
fête devient un enjeu économique les
territoires l'instrumentalise afin de
jouer sur leur image et d'augmenter leur
attractivité tout en boostant le
tourisme pensons différents au club
belge reconnu par l'unesco qui sont
désormais des dix fils internationale
pour des villes belges comme nonce a cru
bon mais plus encore qu'un simple levier
de marketing local la fête devient un
secteur économique à part entière les
organisateurs de l'événementiel les
promoteurs de spectacles les
professionnels de la restauration se
base sur le festif pour développer leurs
activités des acteurs de ce secteur ont
d'ailleurs été des exemples malheureux
des victimes économiques des mesures
sanitaires
dans ce contexte de modernisation de la
fête on constate un découplement entre
le chant festif et la croyance qui était
un lien caractéristiques principales de
la fête traditionnelle l'événement
festif est désormais coupée de tout
enjeu métaphysique
de plus la fête perd sa dimension
collective l'individualisation touche la
fête comme d'autres aspects de la vie
moderne en fonction de son âge de sa
classe sociale de son origine chacun vit
la fête à sa façon et ce mode festif
remplace inexorablement les grands
événements collectifs vécu de manière
uniforme par la collectivité où la
famille en fait la fête est devenue un
loisir comment dit on constate que la
fête moderne a conservé quelques bribes
de la fête traditionnelle mais qui sont
aujourd'hui diluée dans ces nouvelles
logiques commerciales économiques ou de
loisirs à côté des fêtes religieuses ou
des fêtes qui jalonnent la vie de
l'individu de nouveaux espaces de fait
sont apparus et ont vidé la fête de sa
dimension collective à l'échelle de la
société pour ne laisser que l'aspect
social au niveau du groupe la fête et
surtout aujourd'hui perçu comme un
moment de délassement de sociabilité sur
base de la corporalité de l'individu ou
de son affirmation d'une appartenance à
un groupe rapprocher de cette manière de
la sphère des loisirs la fête n'est plus
toujours une nécessité sociale tant les
grandes fêtes officielles que les
rituels villageois comme les bals et
ducasse ainsi que les événements
familiaux traditionnels perdent de leur
normativité c'est à dire qu'ils ne sont
plus suivis en masse de plus la fête
devient quotidienne banalisée
omniprésente d'abord cantonné
principalement week end la fête s'est
installée dans la semaine et même au
travail comme en témoignent les jeux de
redit et autres afterwork sans oublier
la fête commerciale permanente où
s'enchaînent les semaines anniversaires
et autres moments d'hystérie commercial
en schématisant on peut dire que la fête
traditionnelle était importante pour le
collectif et que la fête moderne est
importante pour les individus
l'imposition des règles sanitaires
strictes dès mars 2020 a complètement
bouleversé notre manière de faire la
fête mais si tu as bien suivie jusqu'ici
tu sais que la fête moderne n'avait déjà
plus rien à voir avec la fête
traditionnelle cependant on constate
qu'en tant que vides la fête n'a pas
cessé et s'est adaptée au contexte de la
pandémie les différents types de fait
n'ont pas été impactées de la même façon
par la crise sanitaire c'est une
évidence les fêtes interne à la cellule
familiale ou au groupe d'amis très
proches ont pu se maintenir dans le
cadre privé à l'échelle du couple par
exemple les moments festifs comme les
anniversaires de mariage ou la saint
valentin ont pu continuer en faisant
simplement l'impasse a certainement sur
la sortie à l'extérieur mais la
célébration en elle même n'a jamais
réellement cessé dans des lieux plus
intimes pour le reste les fêtes liées
aux groupes proches ont continué en
diminuant parfois le nombre de convives
afin de respecter les différentes jauges
imposées par les autorités la fête se
fait en groupe en groupe restreint entre
les murs des habitations privées les
festivités officielles ont quant à elles
étaient adaptés afin de répondre aux
dispositions légales
l'instauration de jauge les mesures
distanciation et l'obligation du pass
sanitaires ont permis l'organisation de
fêtes dépassant la sphère privée et la
dizaine de participants de nouvelles
occasions festives éphémères sont
également apparues dans les interstices
du quotidien les réunions d'amis en
extérieur dans les parcs ou en russe se
sont multipliées la moindre occasion
sert de prétexte à la rencontre ou à
boire un coup entre potes les commerces
à emporter ou les abords de certains
cafés les fans jogging ou les sorties
shopping sont devenus de nouveaux
moments de nouveaux lieux de socialité
festive ce type de fait est certainement
encouragé par la succession des
couvre-feux et des confinement qui
limite de facto fortement les
déplacements et surtout les déplacements
nocturnes et toute occasion du urnes
devient alors une occasion de rencontre
et acquiert un potentiel festif
j'aimerais illustré d'ailleurs cela par
un exemple personnel lors du premier
confinement un ami à vous faire une
canette sur le parking d'une grande
surface pour faire comme avant et nous
avions fini par en consommer plus d'une
en refaisant le monde enfin de manière
plus radicale des rassemblements
clandestins parfois de plus de 1000
personnes sont nées à différents moments
de la crise la rave party du nouvel an
en 2020 et de lieuron en ille et vilaine
qui avait réuni plus de 2500 personnes
pendant 36 heures est un exemple de
cette catégorie de fait entendre qu vite
je pense aussi à la boum organisée dans
le bois de la cambre à bruxelles qui a
beaucoup fait parler d'elle
si toi aussi tu as des exemples de façon
de faire la fête en période que vite
n'hésite pas à en faire part dans les
commentaires personnellement je trouve
ça toujours très intéressant d'avoir des
exemples pour bien comprendre les choses
qui ont été expliquées dans la vidéo
comme on vient de le voir des contextes
très strictes et répressif n'empêche pas
la fête et de nouvelles modalités sont
apparus nous pouvons en guise de
conclusion à cette vidéo nous demander
en quoi la fête est si importante qu'on
ne puisse l'arrêter
six ans humaines et sociales se sont
très vite à intéresser aux fêtes dans
les sociétés traditionnelles
anthropologue et sociologue ou proposer
de nombreuses interprétations de ce fait
social durkheim considère que les fêtes
traditionnelles permettent de faire
pénétrer le sacré dans la vie
quotidienne creuse les interprètes comme
des moments où la transgression de
certains interdits de la vie quotidienne
sont permis dans une clause sur base de
son étude du potlatch amérindiens montre
que la fête entremêle différents enjeux
politiques économiques religieux
familiaux juridique ou esthétique pour
celles et ceux qui ignorent ce qu'est le
potlatch il s'agit d'une cérémonie
pratiquée notamment par les tribus
indiennes d'amérique du nord au cours de
laquelle des clans ou des chefs de clans
rivalisent soit en détruisant des objets
soit en faisant des dons au rival qui
est à son tour contraint à donner
davantage du point de vue de
l'anthropologie la fête est donc
essentiel aux collectivités humaines et
comme nous venons de le voir
l'interdiction de certaines modalités
n'a fait que déplacer la fête vers de
nouvelles pratiques preuve de ce besoin
essentiel de faire la fête l'une des
principales fonctions de la fête et de
rythmer la vie humaine en faisant
alterner le quotidien ou les individus
se conform ait des moments de lâcher
prise l'intervalle festif et donc une
soupape qui permet aux individus
d'accepter la routine du quotidien et
les aléas de la vie la fête permet donc
de se détacher périodiquement des
contraintes des frustrations de la
réalité quotidienne sans fait les
individus n'auraient aucun espace pour
se défouler et les pulsions parfois
agressive serait reportée dans d'autres
sphères peut-être sous des formes plus
violente dans le cadre festif les
transgressions reste acceptable et son
cadre est par exemple l'alcoolisme
festif est encadrée par les pairs par la
socialisation les plus jeunes apprennent
à boire au cours de différentes
initiations collective qui si elles sont
parfois excessives il faut l'admettre
seront toujours plus contrôlés que
l'alcoolisme solitaire on pourrait se
demander aussi si le sport les loisirs
peuvent assumer seule cette fonction de
soupape elles ne le peuvent pas ou que
très partiellement car ils sont plus
axés sur l'individu du et sur des
mécanismes de distinction et de
performance alors que les fêtes permette
à l'individu de montrer son appartenance
et de s'identifier à un collectif la
faites vous donc un important rôle de
socialisation et de cohésion sociale que
d'autres institutions ne peuvent remplir
et c'est pourtant de cela que les
individus ont besoin d'ailleurs la
troisième mi-temps les moments de
convivialité où les festivités des
associations sportives et des loisirs
sont des exemples probants que le sport
ou le loisir seuls ne suffisent pas
j'espère que j'ai réussi à exposer de
manière vulgariser mais précise
l'article de laurent sébastien fournier
que j'ai néanmoins saupoudré de nombreux
exemples personnels originaux pour que
ce soit plus parlant pour toi je te
remercie de ton attention et de ton
intérêt et je te dis très bientôt dans
une prochaine vidéo de sciences sociales
à très bientôt
[Musique]